black
army officer pepper sprayed in traffic
stop accuses officer of
assault this is a new york times story
karen nazario karan nazario lieutenant
in the u.s army medical corps was
driving to petersburg virginia from a
drill weekend when he saw police lights
flashing behind him too nervous to stop
on a darkened road lieutenant azaria who
was black and latino drove about a mile
to a gas station pulled over
and placed his cell phone on his
dashboard immediately two windsor police
officers
can be heard yelling orders at him
lieutenant nazario then says
i'm honestly afraid to get out of the
car yeah you should be says one of the
officers according to the footage
from his body camera seconds later the
officer accused uh
dues the lieutenant with pepper spray
lieutenant azaria hands remained up as
he coughed and pleaded with the officer
to undo his seatbelt
and made sure the dog's smoke was not
choking in the back
lieutenant zarya has filed a lawsuit
accusing the officers of illegally
searching his car
using excessive force and violating his
rights under the first amendment the
lawsuit
seeks one million dollars income
compensat compensatory
damages can i pull up the video let's
take a look at this so
this is a shorter video that we can show
i want you to see this and let's i want
to have a reaction to this but i want
you to see this here
the longer one is 31 minutes we're just
gonna use a five minute one we may not
even watch the whole thing but we'll
mount some of the clips of it
lower the audio a little bit
okay pull up go a little bit fast like
yeah there you go this is good
a little more a little
are in your more
open the door slowly step out open the
door
get out of the car
the door slowly and get out this is
december 5th 2020. so four months ago
the guy that's screaming was a corporal
in the marines
his wife was a sailor in the navy not
the guy on camera the guy in the back
that has the camera outside the window
keep your hands outside the window the
guy screaming is a former marine
car now
he has both of his hands out
he's in army fatigue he's an army
fatigue
yo well guess what i'm a veteran too i
learned to obey get out of the car
yep watch this get out of the car now
what's going on is you're fixing to ride
the lightning sun
let me say you're about to ride the ride
the lightning sun is going to taste the
car now
get out of the car now get out of the
car
sir just get out the car work with us
and we'll talk to you get out the car
you received our order obey it i'm
i'm i'm honestly afraid to get out can i
yeah you you should be
get out shut it down get out the car
get out now i have not committed any
crime you're being stopped for a traffic
violation you're not cooperating at this
point right now
you're under arrest for you're being
detained okay you're being detained for
obstructive justice
by the way the guy's being so reasonable
get out of the car now get out of the
car get out of here get your hands off
me you know what
your hands off man
don't do that sir get out of the car now
okay watch this get out of the car now
sir i'm trying to get out okay i'm
trying to call get out
can you please relax get out he's
relaxed get out of the car right now
now that's not how you chew the vet uh
i'm actively serving this country
[Applause]
gosh get out of the car
get out of the car now
there's a better angle sir just get out
the car
get out of the car now
you can't see pepper spraying his eyes
he's struggling
take off your seatbelt and get out of
the car
look i'm just gonna just please he knows
if he puts his hands down
then somebody can shoot him and
potentially say
watch this
take your seatbelt off and get out of
the car don't reach in there daniel
don't reach in there
there's a gun in here by the way he has
a gun in here and they know they saw it
really messed up he's the first
lieutenant officer
get out of the car there's a dog in the
truck
smoke is his name i'm a lieutenant
lieutenant get out of the car says what
are your specialists a corporal he says
i'm a lieutenant
you made this way more difficult than it
had to be you just comply
specialist is an e4 a first lieutenant
you have to go to college to get a
degree
then you become a lieutenant straight on
the ground such a good citizen here
let's go let's go available
being respectful get on the ground get
on the ground
now get on the ground you're getting
sprayed again get on the ground can you
please talk to me about what you're
doing
on the ground shut around now please
talk to me oh god
can you please talk to me about this yes
extremely respectful still the entire
time
okay unfortunately we can't show the
whole clip because we were trying to get
approval on the other video to get
approval we haven't gotten back yet
but uh when you see the whole clip
eventually at the end uh the cop
tries to explain to him look i
understand where you are why did you do
this to yourself
you did this to yourself you shouldn't
have done this you did this to yourself
if you would have listened this would
have never happened et cetera et cetera
and the guy's just sitting there saying
dude
he didn't say nothing he's just staying
quiet you have two options i can either
do this or i can
file charges if i do i know how the army
is going to react as a first lieutenant
this may be bad for your career so what
do you want to do and the guy's like
you're not giving me any choice i have
to read you both choices
and they eventually walk them to the
back to make sure smoke is doing good
smoke is doing good they stay with them
for 20 to 40 minutes and then eventually
the guy apparently
leaves and he's now asking for a million
bucks the footage comes out
but what do you react when you see
someone like this either one of you guys
how do you react to this you know there
there's so much
divisiveness in our country um
blue lives matter black lives matter
social justice getting woke
diversify this that you know i'm a cop i
support the troops there's so much of
that
and at the end of the day and this
highlights it all it's like
are you on the side of our troops or are
you on the side of the cops well they're
they're fighting against each other
so which one is it i think really what
it comes down to is
right and wrong and i think anyone
watching this
knows that the cops were wrong in that
situation and i'm sure there's going to
be people that are saying
no the cop was right and the guy but
from from a layman's perspective
just from a human perspective
the cops are like they can
escalate a situation or they can
de-escalate a situation yep
i don't know what they're taught and
this is i try to have zero interaction
with the cops for that matt
like i i rarely interact with cops when
i do it's
do you like cops or do you not like cops
traditionally i would have said i don't
like cops okay i'm just being honest
because every time i've been dealt with
a cop it's been a situation like that
pulled over in a car i've had guns drawn
on me before
driving through miami they thought it
was a drug deal or whatever like i've
had bad incidents with cops
a cop never i never see them at a shop
that's like hey how's your day going
good
yeah so i bought this that's my
perspective
but i understand that they're 99 of cops
are good cops i get that that's a bad
perspective to have
i get it but you can escalate a
situation or you can de-escalate a
situation like we talked about earlier
in the show about do people want to be
told what to do or do they want to
choose what to do
so when you have a cop yelling a
thousand times get on the ground
get on the ground do what you're told
obey your orders and the guy's like look
man
i'mma you can see what i'm wearing here
i'm a lieutenant in the army can we just
have a conversation
and the cop has zero reasonable
qualities get out get out get it like
what is that i'm asking a question like
what is that why can't he say hey look
man
we pulled you over because of this
here's what we need you to do we
understand that you're a lieutenant or
sergeant
we'd like you to comply but they're just
freaking out on this guy
spraying pepper spray in his face it's
disgusting the guy's gonna likely win
the lawsuit
tom the most dangerous thing that the
police
do factually and statistically is walk
up to a car they pulled over
that is the most dangerous thing that
they do and at night it's even more
dangerous
however cops can't be on
ego drive and ego trips about who they
are and what they do
in this case they followed the guy he
did not pull over immediately he was
concerned so he goes to a well-lit gas
station and is cooperating
with a quiet voice with his hands
outside in full
visibility in this case the most
dangerous thing they do is walk up to a
vehicle
the police have an obligation to do
their job properly
and they didn't they could just walk up
and they could have de-escalated this
the police could have de-escalated it
and now with a reasonable guy being
reasonable keeping his hands there we
can see him any other occupants no sir
there's not my dog's in the back
then they pepper spray him from six feet
away when they can see him in a
compliant pose
these cops escalated it when they were
concerned when they pulled him over they
didn't know what they had
and he apparently didn't pull over for a
mile so he didn't know what they had but
they say they want to get to a well-lit
area
but they that's right it's up very well
that was actually safer for the cops and
safer for the guys
they could see and so the cops even if
they're nervous about it hey this guy's
not pulling over at first what are we
going to do oh my gosh what are we going
to do okay fine
but once you're there you as a police
officer if you're going to be a cop and
you're going to
continue to be a cop you have to play
both sides you have to calm yourself
down
even as you're getting yourself amped up
to protect yourself and your
uh partner but you have to then
de-escalate you have to do it properly
all the time they didn't and i think
it's disgusting
that they pepper sprayed the guy from
six feet while being completely
compliant and showing his hands
so that part of it is way out of line so
here's what i think here's what i think
years ago nine years ago a year ago we
brought in mark lamb
i don't know if you remember mark lam
not even a year ago maybe like 10 months
ago sheriff mark
sheriff mark he called into the show and
we brought him on and i interviewed him
right after when they talked about the
defunding of the police right here we
need to defund the police so i brought
him in
and i interviewed him and i cannot tell
you how many how much hate letters i got
email how dare you put a guy like this
on at a time like this
america going through this and you you
you you would
you would highlight a cop like him and
even
we heard from one of his friends from
the past okay we're like listen we don't
want to participate in this
calling us giving recording we don't
want anything like this we just did an
interview is what we did here right
so the same people that got upset at
officer lamb the opposing party is like
well listen we're so glad you brought
them on because it's about defunding the
police nobody we shouldn't defund the
police
this i highlight here and people come
back will say why would you show
something like this that's so divisive
this is how i believe media needs to be
you need to give both sides on what's
going on and call out when somebody
fully screws up
let me explain to what happened this
situation here um
i don't know what it is to be black you
don't know what it is to be from
iran looking like me okay i don't know
what it is to be white i don't know what
it is to be norway i don't know what it
is to be from venezuela
from colombia from mexico from else i
don't know what it is all i know how to
be
is to be middle eastern half armenian
half assyrian from iran
who looks like this with this nose with
this ear i don't look like the average
human i look like i'm a middle eastern
this is all i know what to look like
have i gotten people that have uh uh
what do you call it stereotypes you know
racial what a prejudice
yeah of course you know was it a lot of
jokes in the military hey
did you go to school on a donkey you
know
are you like a camel jockey i'm like
dude i've never seen a camel in my life
but i get it you know you're saying
whatever you're saying
fine i get it have i heard all those
things i have are you fresh off the boat
i'm a pretty good swimmer by the way so
yeah i don't know if i'm fresh off the
boat but i'm a good damn swimmer right
i don't know what it is to be black i
have no idea what it is to be black
i don't i don't know what it is to have
cops pulling you over
at a time like this in december by the
way this is not right now where things
are commerce this is december
right after election when all the
protesting's still going on you got
capital
all this stuff and this guy's getting
pulled over he's sitting there thinking
i'm about to go his grandma was a former
nypd for 30 years by the way if you
listen to the whole story
yeah this guy right here he loves
america this is a pro america guy
that loves america he's just saying dude
i do not want to get pulled over in a
dark place let me go to a gas station
you go to a gas station the guy pulls
over you you do what you do to him i
mean
then let's talk about the cops let's
look at the cops what are the cops
worried about
so the cops worried about what what do
you what if you know it's extremely
sensitive what the hell are you doing
overreacting remember one time i got
pulled over by a cop in plano i said
i've never been pulled over by a nice
cop like this before
and it was uncomfortable do you remember
when i talked about on a podcast too
nice
he was being too nice i'm like why are
you being so nice he says you don't know
the climate right now being a cop
i have to overly be nice he says may i
please get the license sir thank you so
much for cooperating i'm like this
sounds like customer service
at like the place that makes no sense
nordstrom's just now training cops yeah
yeah
neiman marcus type of customer service
it made no sense to me the cop that he
handled me and playing i'm like dude
i was speeding that was reckless driving
i went over the side of the road
all everything you're saying i did so
why are you being so nice i was being a
little reckless the way i drove i was so
he's like here's a ticket that was a
pretty good sized ticket points all this
other so i have to deal with that okay
great no problem
i deserved the fine that i got but i was
concerned why the cop was so
scared so that's far one side
this is far the complete opposite side
now let's talk about a different part
about this
um had a friend of mine years ago i'm
not going to say his name i had a friend
of mine years ago
we were very close to the point we
partied every weekend together we were
close together very very close i'm
talking 20 years ago
this guy was the biggest sweetheart adam
i know
biggest sweetheart i know i'm when i say
sweetheart i'm talking sweetheart
and guess what he did for a living he
was a nurse
guess what he ends up becoming after
being a nurse he becomes let me guess a
cop
a cop okay when i tell you the biggest
sweetheart i'm not telling you it was
the biggest sweetheart because it just
sounds good
maybe one of the top five biggest
sweethearts i know in my life was this
guy
then he becomes a cop then he gets the
badge then he gets the gun
then i go out to lunch with them six
months later a little different
the way he talked to the customer the
way he talked to the waitress six months
later
little different the way he talked to
people two years later
little different three years later
little different four years later
temper flaring regularly huh
what the hell is going on to this guy
this is not the guy was friends with
five years later a little worse then
eventually gets fired okay
from the police force on the police
force wow and that rarely happens there
was some controversy there
but anyways i will tell you
that badge and the gun that gives you
that kind of power reveals a lot of deep
dark sides of a human being that's not
ready to be a cop
they're just not so on one end
it comes up from the guy that's running
it the chief on how they
shape the mindset of a cop if the chief
says
we are the badge we have the gun they
better listen to you or else you drop
their asses these mother
okay if you're teaching me like that
dude you're firing me i'm like oh my
gosh
but if you're saying hey these are
citizens we work for the city the
taxpayers are paying for us
we got to make sure respect everybody
everyone's innocent until proven guilty
you got to be a little bit paranoid you
got to be careful
and it may not be easy but that's what
we got to do that's what we got to do
i'm going to newport beach one time i'm
going to newport beach with a business
meeting guys what's happening i'm
speaking on this yet i'm 21 years old 22
years old
i got seven people in my car we're all
we're all suited up we're young we're 21
22 years old
we're driving down to newport i bet
couple of the friends are gonna remember
this event if they're listening to the
podcast right now we're driving down to
newport
guy pulls me over he comes to the side
with gun point at the cars like this i'm
like
he comes like put your head on her
steering wheel i'm like what the hell
i'm not in a place to talk to me like
that at 21 years old i was not
reasonable i wasn't
out of the military i just got out of
military i'm like dude i am on fire like
i am on fire at this time right
so i put my hands on the stairs i said
what the hell are you doing so what the
hell are you doing
are you rookie how long have you been a
cop tell me you look like you're a
rookie cop how long have you been a cop
are you a rookie cop you're a rookie cop
ain't you so him and i start going at it
and my guy's like pat calm down calm
down calm down
they're right i was overreacting but i
was pissed off you rookie cop
you're rookie cop why are you pulling me
over you 170. i'm like at 65.
he said well you're going five minutes
five miles over speed i see you cannot
tell me
you give me a speeding ticket at 70
going 65 on a four or five
i am i said there's a bunch of people
going faster than me he said well it's
like fishing
sometimes when you fish you don't catch
all the fish you're the fish i caught
today
i'm like this mother i said okay give me
the ticket i want to show to court
so i want to see what the hell are you
going to do about it so i go to court
and he's there and i'm asking everybody
officer do you know who that is i do how
long has been a cop he's a newer cop
oh he's a newer cop yeah anyways the
judge gives me all this stuff that
i told you were rookie cop you gave a
ticket at 70
going 70 years old 70 miles out of 65
when you come up with a gun with six
people sitting in the back wood all
suited up what the hell are you doing
this is exactly why cops get a bad rep
sometimes now
gosh somebody comes into our house a few
months ago cops show up three of them
okay everyone's concerned cops show up
sir is everything okay you guys
comfortable do you need to stay here
ma'am is there anything you want us to
do you want us to walk through every
room
please i will do that matter of fact how
about i do that so you're comfortable
melville are you okay
they want to walk anything else you need
here's our number give us a call we're
here to help you
the most ridiculous experience 80 of my
experiences with cops have always been
good
20 of them have been bad of the 20 that
have been bad
probably 80 of it was because i was
being bad so that was at a different
phase of my life where i was acting like
a fool
so you understand how to math one right
there 80 20 20 80 of it was my fault so
20 of it wasn't my fault
it's a very slim margin but when you do
things like this and it goes on camera
you officially hurt other cops that get
the reputation
and a media station shows this to the
world and they don't
they don't tell the story the right way
they spin it as all the cops are like
this
and then everyone reacts then there's
division then we have what we have today
in america go ahead are you noticing
us um a similarity in your stories in my
stories and the stories that we're
showing
where are all these bad incidents
happening
on the frickin road in a car cops show
up to your house
yeah okay because you call the burglary
or whatever they're
like that a rarely happens and they're
there to defuse what happened what's
going on
for whatever reason the the like you
said most
um incidents happen in the car
artistically the most dangerous thing
that cop does is come to the window of
your car
we're keying in on what the fear is from
cops
and from drivers and like you've said
we've i've never been black you've been
black
this guy is scared to get out of his car
and he's a freaking lieutenant in the
army first lieutenant okay
imagine if you're just a normal guy in
atlanta
or illinois or california and you're
just
on the road and you're going 70 in a in
a 65
the cop pulls you over draws the gun and
you've seen a million of these freaking
stories
how are you supposed to react you know
the black people you know they have the
talk
you always hear i have to have to talk
with my kids i have to have to talk to
my kids you're talking about that last
night michael strange
all right look you're going to grow up
and you're going to meet a girl and the
birds and the bees the talk these days
if you're in a black household is
you're going to get mother freaking
pulled over and this is how you need to
speak to them
like there's this is a thing now this is
reality so you can't dismiss how people
feel
and if a lieutenant is scared to get out
of the car
serving america imagine just put
yourself in the shoes of just a normal
black person in america
how they would feel okay you you've had
a bad incident with a cop
in a car i've had a ton of them to the
point where i can't even drive a car
so a person's saying right now the guy
clearly didn't follow the instructions
and he should have opened the door see
the challenge but that's the first thing
i said
but if you watch the whole 31 minute
clip which i highly recommend i don't
know what channel it is let's give a
shout out to matt if i put it below so
people can watch it afterwards
just watch the whole 31 minute clip to
see what happens
there the reason why he didn't
automatically open the door is because
when you open the door the gun is here
so imagine if he opens the door and they
see the gun they react the guy
knows there's going to be a reaction so
there was a gun in there
all his gear was in the back he was
moving because he was getting orders
to go to a different place so you kind
of have to see the whole story
that's a legally owned weapon it is it
is but still you open it you see a
reaction and somebody shoots
you're panicking in that moment nobody
knows what it's like to have only a few
people in the world have been held gun
you know you don't know how to react
when that's taking place it's a very
weird reaction and people react in a
different way
all of us can say whatever he should
have done this but there's a little bit
more to the story look i'm
i'm a guy that defends cops 90 percent
of the time i'm i
i love great cops i sleep better at
night because of great cops i travel
better because of great cops i
have put great events together because
of great cops great cops have taken care
of me and my family
my entire life i'm a byproduct of great
cops
cops like this need to get trained
better you need to get you know the same
way i say uh the teachers terrible
teachers need to be fired yeah
terrible cops need to be fired asap
terrible cops who cannot handle like you
know how you do pressure
type of training i'm watching a video
this morning of the guy who's the guy
that uh he came up with the
uh uh the torturing thing what's his
expertise
james mitchell is the guy that came up
with cia's method to
waterboard enhanced interrogation this
guy very interesting story he's got
there right so
the interviewer says before i interview
you i wanted to be waterboarded so he
goes and gets waterboarded okay
just to kind of get a feel by the way i
wouldn't mind doing that just to know
what it feels like
wow so he gets waterboarded that's an
episode right there then he does the
interview
okay then he says it's terrible being
waterboarded
right he's explaining to him what it's
like to be waterboarded so dude
the reaction to this was absolutely
insane
okay so what should we do should we get
rid of the bad guys should we keep this
bad guy should we do this
i think cops who are doing things like
this they should get fired i think bad
teachers should be fired i think we need
to just clean house
if you cannot handle being rattled in a
high pressure type situation
you are not qualified to be a cop and
that's not your job that's not
simply your job you need to go do
something else but definitely not be a
cop
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye